WITH A HIGH CONCENTRATION OF
THAT VULNERABLE AGE GROUP, A LOT
OF PEOPLE RETIRE IN FLORIDA.
BUT FIRST TONIGHT, I RETURNED
TWO OF THE WORST CANDIDATES EVER
TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT AFTER
DODGING A VERY SERIOUS
SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLEGATION FOR
OVER A MONTH.
TODAY, JOE BIDEN TEAMED UP WITH
NONE OTHER THAN HILLARY CLINTON.
THEY HAD A TOWN HALL FOCUSING ON
WOMEN’S ISSUES.
YOU CAN’T EVEN MAKE THIS UP.
OF COURSE, HILLARY CLINTON HAS
QUITE A TRACK RECORD ON WOMEN’S
ISSUES, NOTABLY ENABLING SOMEONE
SAY HER HUSBAND AND NUMEROUS
COVERUPS, SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
ALLEGATIONS DURING HIS POLITICAL
CAREER AND TAKING MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM
COUNTRIES THAT ABUSED WOMEN.
NOW COINCIDENTALLY ENOUGH DURING
THE VIRTUAL TOWN HALL ON WOMEN’S
ISSUES, THE VERY CREDIBLE
SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLEGATION
AGAINST BIDEN DIDN’T COME UP
ONCE.
INSTEAD, HILLARY CLINTON AND
JOE BIDEN FOCUSED ON OTHER
ISSUES.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> GETTING READY TO GO TO A
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL DANCE AND
DIDN’T HAVE ANY CUFFLINKS SO HIS
VERY CREATIVE MOTHER GOT HIM A
NUT AND BOLT AND MADE A CARE PAI
CUFFLINKS FOR HIM.
I THINK HE SAID HE WAS MORTIFIED
BY THAT AND SHE JUST LOOKED AT
HIM AND SAID JOEY, IF SOMEBODY
SAYS SOMETHING TO YOU ABOUT YOUR
CUFFLINKS, YOU JUST SAY WHAT,
YOU DON’T HAVE A PAIR LIKE THAT?
>> Sean: OKAY, JOEY.
AFTER THEY GOT SOME AWKWARD
SMALL TALK OUT OF THE WAY,
HILLARY CLINTON ENTHUSIASTICALLY
FINALLY JUMPED ON THE BIDEN
EXPRESS AND HE BECAME VERY
SLEEPY, TOOK A LONG TIME.
TAKE A LOOK.
IN >> I WANT TO ADD MY VOICE TO
THE MANY WHO HAVE ENDORSED YOU
TO BE OUR PRESIDENT.
JUST THINK OF WHAT A DIFFERENCE
IT WOULD MAKE RIGHT NOW IF WE
HAD A PRESIDENT WHO NOT ONLY
LISTENED THE SCIENCE, PUT FACTS
OVER FICTION, BUT TAUGHT US
TOGETHER.
>> Sean: TIME FOR JOE’S NAP,
LIKE MANY OTHER TOP DEMOCRATS,
THEY SHARED HER FAVORITE PART OF
THE CORONAVIRUS.
IS THERE A FAVORITE PART,
REALLY?
FOR HER IN SO MANY LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS, THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHOVE UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE DOWN
THE THROATS OF WE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> NEEDS TO BE PART OF A MUCH
LARGER SYSTEM THAT EVENTUALLY
AND QUICKLY I HOPE GETS ST
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE.
SO I CAN ONLY SAY AMEN TO
EVERYTHING YOU’RE SAYING, BUT
ALSO TO ENLIST PEOPLE THAT THIS
WOULD BE A TERRIBLE CRISIS AS
THE OLD SAYING GOES.
WE’VE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT WHAT
OUR ABSOLUTE FRAILTIES ARE IN
OUR COUNTRY WHEN IT COMES TO
HEALTH JUSTICE AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE SO LET’S BE RESOLVED
THAT WE ARE GOING TO RESOLVE
THOSE ONCE YOU’RE ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
>> I PROMISE YOU, THAT’S GOING
TO BE MY OBJECTIVE.
>> Sean: A LOT OF ENERGY
THERE.
TO RECAP, A TOWN HALL FOCUSED ON
WOMEN, HILLARY CLINTON BRAGGING
HOW COVID-19 COULD HELP
DEMOCRATS POLITICALLY.
JOE SAID THE SAME THING VERY
SIMILAR HIMSELF.
NEVER ONCE BROUGHT UP THE VERY
SERIOUS AND CREDIBLE
SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST BIDEN AND SAID SHE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY ENDORSED HIM.
REMEMBER, IT WAS HILLARY, DID
SAY SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS HAVE
A RIGHT TO BE BELIEVED.
WE’LL TALK ABOUT THE EYE
BELIEVERS IN A SECOND LET’S GO
DOWN MEMORY LANE.
>> I WANT TO SEND A MESSAGE TO
EVERY SURVIVOR OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
DON’T LET ANYONE SILENCE YOUR
VOICE.
YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO BE HEARD,
AND YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO BE
BELIEVED.
WE ARE WITH YOU.
>> Sean: WHAT CHANGED,
HILLARY?
WERE YOU LYING FOR POLITICAL
GAIN?
A WOMAN BY THE NAME OF TERRA
READER.
A FoxNews.com TELLS CLINTON IS
ENABLING A PREDATOR.
KEEP IN MIND, READE IS A
LIFELONG DEMOCRAT.
SHE WAS A STAUNCH SUPPORTER OF
BARACK OBAMA, SO MUCH SO THAT
SHE NEVER WENT PUBLIC WITH THIS
INFORMATION ABOUT HIS RUNNING
MATE AND AS OF TONIGHT, HER
ALLEGATIONS HAVE BEEN
CORROBORATED NOW BY AT LEAST
FOUR INDIVIDUALS THAT SHE
CONFIDED IN SHORTLY AFTER THE
INCIDENT IN 1993, HER MOTHER
EVEN CALLING INTO
"LARRY KING LIVE" AT THE TIME TO
ASK FOR ADVICE.
TARA REID HAS FILED A CRIMINAL
POLICE REPORT AND ACCORDING TO
"THE DAILY CALLER"," NOW CALLING
ON JOE BIDEN TO RELEASE
PERSONNEL RECORDS FROM THE
SENATE OFFICE THAT SHE BELIEVES
WILL CONTAIN A COPY OF HER
OFFICIAL COMPLAINT ABOUT THE
INCIDENT.
SO IS JOE GOING TO BE
TRANSPARENT OR RELEASE THOSE
RECORDS OR AS WE SPEAK MAGICALLY
BLEACH FITTED AND DISAPPEARING
AND WILL ANYONE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OR THE MOB AND
THE MEDIA -- THAT’S RIGHT, ALL
THESE DEMOCRATIC POTENTIAL VP
CANDIDATES WERE AND ASKED A
QUESTION ABOUT IT.
ARE THEY GOING TO ASK HIM ABOUT
THESE ACCUSATIONS?
YESTERDAY, WE REACHED OUT FOR
COMMENT FROM BIDEN’S POTENTIAL
RUNNING MATE.
HE SAYS HE’S PICKING A WOMAN.
ALL WOMEN TODAY, MANY HAVE NOT
ADDRESSED READE’S ALLEGATIONS
DIRECTLY INCLUDING
SENATOR AMY KLOBUCHAR WHO
APPARENTLY HAS NO REAL COURAGE
WHATSOEVER, STACY ABRAMS GAVE A
WHOLEHEARTEDLY BIG DEFENSE OF
BIDEN TODAY SAYING JOE WILL MAKE
WOMEN PROUD AND THEN
SENATOR KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND
ACCORDING TO NBC NEWS, THE
MORALLY BANKRUPT SENATOR FROM
NEW YORK TOLD REPORTERS "I STAND
BY PRESIDENT BIDEN, HE’S DEVOTED
HIS LIFE TO SUPPORTING WOMEN AND
HE HAS VEHEMENTLY DENIED THIS
ALLEGATION.
IN 2018, THE TWO-FACED SENATOR
FROM NEW YORK SAID SHE BELIEVED
KAVANAUGH’S ACCUSER.
SHE HAD NO CORROBORATING
EVIDENCE, NO WITNESSES AND STILL
INDICATED THAT KAVANAUGH’S
DENIAL DIDN’T EVEN MATTER.
CALLED FOR HIS NOMINATION TO BE
WITHDRAWN.
WHAT CHANGED,
SENATOR GILLIBRAND?
THEY PROTECT QUID PRO QUO JOE?
COME TO THINK OF IT, WHAT
HAPPENED TO ALL OF THE EYE
BELIEVERS?
WE ARE THEY?
REMEMBER THIS.
>> I BELIEVE HER.
FIRST OF ALL, ANYBODY WHO COMES
FORWARD AT THIS POINT TO BE
PREPARED TO TESTIFY IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE AGAINST
SOMEONE WHO IS BEING NOMINATED
TO ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL
POSITIONS IN THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT, THAT TAKES AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF COURAGE.
>> NOT ONLY DO WOMEN LIKE
DR. FORD WHO BRAVELY COME
FORWARD NEED TO BE HEARD, BUT
THEY NEED TO BE BELIEVED.
>> LET ME SAY RIGHT AT THE
OUTSET, I BELIEVE DR. FORD.
I BELIEVE THE SURVIVOR HERE.
THERE IS EVERY REASON TO BELIEVE
HER.
SHE HAS COME FORWARD
COURAGEOUSLY AND BRAVELY.
>> I BELIEVE HER, I STAND WITH
HER.
>> DO YOU HOPE THAT SHE
TESTIFIES?
>> I DON’T THINK SHE PROBABLY
DONE THIS SCENARIO.
>> I THINK SHE’S CREDIBLE AND I
THINK WHEN THE INVESTIGATION IS
FINISHED AND WHEN SHE TESTIFIES
AND JUDGE KAVANAUGH TESTIFIES, I
THINK A MAJORITY OF SENATORS
WILL FIND HER CREDIBLE.
>> Sean: DO YOU BELIEVE TARA
REID?
NOW REMEMBER, THAT ALLEGATION
WITH PROFESSOR FORD WAS AN
ALLEGATION WITH ZERO
CORROBORATION, ZERO WITNESSES,
NO POLICE REPORT.
TABERTARA READE, CHECK.
ONCE PRAISE THE COURAGE OF
KAVANAUGH’S ACCUSER BUT IS NOW
REFUSING TO SAY ANYTHING ABOUT
TARA REID.
SHE SUPPORTING BIDEN THIS WEEK.
MEANWHILE, MORE PREDICTABLE
HYPOCRISY FROM THE MOB AND YOUR
MEDIA.
"WASHINGTON POST" REPORTED
"DEVELOPMENTS AND ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST BIDEN AMPLIFY EFFORTS TO
QUESTION HIS BEHAVIOR."
OKAY, LET’S COMPARE THAT WORD
SALAD TO THIS HEADLINE ABOUT
KAVANAUGH.
"CALLS FOR JUSTICE KAVANAUGH’S
IMPEACHMENT ARE MOUNTING.
HERE’S HOW IT COULD WORK.
IN THAT LOOK LIKE FAIR AND
BALANCED JOURNALISM FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST"?
I DON’T THINK SO.
OF COURSE NOT.
THIS IS THE CONSTANT DECEPTION
THAT IS HURTING OUR COUNTRY.
WE HAVE AN INFORMATION CRISIS IN
AMERICA AND THE MOB IN THE MEDIA
ARE NOTHING MORE THAN STATE RUN
TV PROPAGANDA OF THE EXTREME
RADICAL DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
PARTY AND ALL THINGS HATE
DONALD TRUMP EVERY SECOND MINUTE
AND HOUR OF EVERY DAY AND
THEY’RE TRYING HARDER THAN EVER
TO PROP UP SOMEBODY WHO IS
STRUGGLING TO SAY IT CHARITABLY,